this video was sponsored by amc's the
walking dead
world beyond welcome to rick's walking
dead emporium
thanks for having me it is uh rough out
there these days
so what you selling oh you know stuff
and things
oh very descriptive i
guess i'll just look around oh
this this is very interesting i haven't
seen anything like this before
do you mind telling me what this is
coral
hello internet welcome to film theory
hey coral what's glen's favorite
restaurant dad
please don't pop eyes popeyes coral
ah rick you might be gone but your memes
shamble on like an undead walker except
that brings up
a really important question where is
rick grimes i think everyone who started
watching the walking dead always assumed
that at some point rick would have to
die in some massive act of heroism
he was our favorite southern sheriff the
protagonist of the whole show in a
series where everyone was at constant
risk of biting the big one
or getting bit by the big one more
accurately
and season 9 episode 5 what comes after
seemed like it was going to be that
moment our leader rick after losing his
wife his son
his friends heck even his own humanity
during his journey is mortally wounded
and facing down a marching zombie
onslaught headed straight to the
survivor's settlement
i mean this is it nine and a half
seasons in the making
this was his climax he makes the hard
choice to blow up a bridge and
him along with it the plan works the
zombies are thwarted rick is blown away
but shocking everyone he doesn't die
he's instead airlifted away in a
mysterious helicopter via some sort of
bizarre trade negotiated by former
villain jadis
i have a bee not an a i never had today
he's heard but he's strong can you help
him
not a trick not anymore i'm trying to
save a friend
but friend who saved me i have something
for you now we have a deal
do we have a deal so why am i talking
about this now
this is old news as far as the walking
dead's concerned we're already a season
beyond this moment
well first the mystery of the helicopter
people is probably the most
significant mystery of the walking dead
franchise outside of you know what
started the zombie outbreak in the first
place
and even that one might already be
solved if series creator robert kirkman
is to be believed since he gave us these
two words on twitter
space spore so with rick being the main
character of the original series what
happens to him is a pretty important
question
especially when he officially has a
trilogy of movies coming out to tell the
rest of his story
but the why now question also relates
back to this
the announcement of a third series
another branch on the walking dead media
franchise obviously the original is
still going
and honestly stronger than it's ever
been with its ongoing battle against the
whispers in virginia
then we have the spin-off prequel of
fear the walking dead which started with
a group of survivors in los angeles
california and is currently following
him through texas and
this month the walking dead world beyond
joins the fray and from what little we
know about world beyond this one is
actually
significantly different according to
what the creative teams have said about
this new series
world beyond takes place a full decade
after the zombie outbreak and it focuses
on the gen z
teens who have known nothing but life
with zombies and can i just say if the
gen zers and world beyond don't refer to
themselves as generation z
for zombie that is a missed opportunity
guys it's apparently a limited series
event consisting of just two
10 episode seasons then it's done it's a
more optimistic
upbeat show more adventure than horror
focused around quote a heroic group of
teens sheltered from the dangers of the
post-apocalyptic world who leave the
safety of the only home they've ever
known and embark on a cross-country
journey to find the one man who can
possibly save the world
but look again at some of that trailer
footage i've been showing you notice the
helicopter you see that three-ring
symbol
it's the same group that abducted rick
and jadis
in short this new series seems to be the
linchpin in the ongoing mystery around
rick
and the helicopter people and if i have
any hope of solving who these people are
before it's revealed in the shows
now is my time to strike and that my
friends
is the why now also because i want to do
this video back in march but then covet
hit but then the series got delayed and
then hey look the walking dead wanted to
sponsor this episode so let's just get
into it the walking dead at this point
is basically the mcu
with clues to this mystery being
sprinkled across all its different
avenues
in the first episode of season five of
fear the walking dead
al is attacked by a very special zombie
which is santalan franchise that kills
these things off by the boat load
the literal boatload sometimes what
makes this particular walker special is
that he's wearing a weird type of body
armor black vertical stripes it's very
slimming when al checks the zombie's
pockets
she finds this a series of maps and
transparent overlays all with the
three-ring markings of the helicopter
people
and all labeled with three letters c
r m maps and overlays that directly
parallel what we see briefly in one of
the trailers for walking dead world
beyond
a map of new york and again the three
letters c
r m four episodes later in fear the
walking dead we actually get to speak to
one of the helicopter people isabelle
and she tells us
well not a lot but but a bit more we
know that crm
is the group's name that their wacky
outfits are filled with wires in order
to be bite proof and then the place i'm
from
i'm not going to tell you where it is
i'm not going to tell you what it's
called but there is something i will
tell you if they figure out how to read
the map it makes what we have
what we're working towards vulnerable
this is about the future
and rebuilding what we all once had so
with all this talk about the future it
seems like the crm group is working on a
cure
or potentially creating children who are
immune to the zombie virus and i do mean
creating children you see that's how
gene therapy works where in very rough
terms new genes are added to a patient's
cells to replace missing or
malfunctioning genes if done early
enough in an embryo's development the
gene transfer can occur in all cells of
the developing embryo leading to
permanent changes that are passed down
to subsequent generations in other words
in a world where we know
pretty much everyone is infected by the
zombie virus
space spore whatever change needs to
happen at the cellular
level affecting each and every cell so
that humanity can get back to as isabel
said
the world it once had gene therapy might
just be the only solution but for it to
work it has to be
in children children i say children like
the ones we see
living with the helicopter people
children like the ones that we're going
to be spending a lot of time with
throughout world beyond and everything
changed
the end of the world was our beginning
that line from the trailer may wind up
being more literal than they expected in
fact
these aren't just any children they
share a common trait a common bond
looking at some of the earliest released
footage from the series the group has a
special name
we are the endlings sounds like the sort
of name i would give a special science
project out to solve the world's genetic
crisis
this focus on genetics and gene-based
solutions to the world zombie problem
isn't just me grasping at straws here
either let's go back to what jada says
to the helicopter operator before they
pick up her
and rick i have a b not an a i never had
today
he's hard but he's strong can you help
him clearly jadis is training humans
with the crm for supplies we see here
eating from a can bearing the three-ring
logo
as well as her eventual escape and this
trading system is somehow tied to the
division of
a's and b's in season 9 episode 3 jadis
is told by the helicopter people via
walkie talkie that she needs an
a what will it take she apparently gave
him heath who disappeared back in season
seven she tried to give him negan
before he managed to escape and she
almost gave him father gabriel but
what does all of this mean what is the
crm looking for
what is this division of a's versus b's
well it appears that anyone marked as an
a
is one a strong leader and two needs to
be recently bitten or about to turn
in season 8 episode 6 jadis puts rick in
a shipping container with the letter
a later that season episode 14 she does
it again with negan
in both cases she tries to get a zombie
to bite them but they
escape before she manages to do it but
it's father gabriel who gives us our
biggest clue
jadis originally had him pegged as a bee
before he stands up to her she offers
him a chance to escape via the
helicopter
and he turns it down whatever this is i
can't do it i have to tell rick
and all this time i thought you were a b
this shows a strength of will that both
negan and rickshare putting him
solidly in the a category next we see
him season 9 episode 4
gabriel the newly deemed a is also tied
up
and ready for the zombie bite there's
only one place left for me to go and
you're the price of admission so an a is
a strong-willed person who's newly
bitten
someone who will fight off the infection
for as long as possible the way i see it
they get bit and are immediately carried
off in the helicopter
because their strong-willed a's they
fight off the infection for as long as
possible allowing the crm enough time to
fly them to their walled off protected
community to do whatever experimentation
or observation they need of the newly
infected individuals they're looking for
the genetic code to break this case
wide open and they need the a's to do it
but there's more
at world beyond's new york comic-con
panel last october chief content officer
scott gimple revealed that the crm's
three-ringed logo is representative of a
network of three communities
united in rebuilding society quote from
him we've seen that three-circle symbol
those three circles and
i'm saying it here represent three
different civilizations that are bound
and entwined in some ways and in some
ways
very very different and quote this led
many to believe that the three letters
of crm relate to the three communities
or the states that they're found in
i actually disagree we see from isabel
in fear the walking dead that this is an
incredibly secret
organization using coded maps to
disguise their location
we learn that team members who deviate
from their mission must be wiped out and
that the crm comes complete with
reclamation teams that eliminate any
unauthorized individual who even has a
hint of what their secret operation
might be so to think that they would
create a cute name from their initials
like some sort of post-apocalyptic in
sync seems a little out of character
no based on their strict code and
technological strength i'd say that this
is more of a military operation with the
m
as militia or military and the cr as
some sort of general reference to the
overall group like
city reclamation capital reestablishment
civic
republic you see in a leaked shot from
set we see these words
civic republic omaha portland it appears
to be the same stage where we see iris
our main character speaking in the world
beyond footage even down to the
reference to monument day it's called
monument day because we are all
monuments to the past
crm civic republic military or militia
one of the two but perhaps the biggest
question is
where i started this episode talking
about rick and his future so knowing
that he was taken by the crm group
where was he taken to i want you to live
don't chase this story
do not try to find me gonna have to give
that one a big old negatory there izzy
like al i just gotta chase the story so
we know that whatever crm
is they're gonna be spread across the
country we've already seen their
helicopters appearing in virginia for
the walking dead
and texas for fear the walking dead and
we know it's three separate communities
based on early footage the world beyond
kids are starting their journey at a crm
facility in nebraska
notice that she's speaking at nebraska
state university the logo
on a sweatshirt and just a whole lot of
nsu imagery throughout the trailer this
is confirmed in a later trailer when
they say
this thing we're doing flowing cross
country is big and then looking at a map
of new york
nebraska to new york certainly a
cross-country journey going back to that
leaked image of iris speaking at
monument day we can reasonably assume
that the second ring of the civic
republic is portland oregon
it says right there on the banner but
for ring number three i think that's
somewhere different i think it's where
rick was taken
you see a teaser for the first walking
dead movie has already started to be
released and with it comes a pretty cool
easter egg a helicopter flies off to a
city in the distance
notice the silhouette of that city it's
the skyline of philadelphia you see that
sloping building right there it's
probably the most unique of the bunch
that's the fmc tower tall pointy one
that's one liberty place
philly's first skyscraper and probably
most notably that really tall collection
right there it's the comcast technology
center so it looks like rick has gotten
himself a one-way ticket to a zombie
cure with a side of cheese steak
so there you have it my friends my
predictions for the future of the
walking dead universe the crm or civic
republic military an organization based
in
omaha portland and philadelphia is going
to be doing genetic therapy research
using children
and an ab demarcation system in adults
to try and find a cure for the zombie
outbreak they're not quite
bad guys i mean they are working on a
cure to save the world but they're
extreme in their methods in a gotta
crack a few eggs to make an omelet sort
of way which in turn leads many to
question their motives iris's father
the one they're searching for in the
world beyond is some sort of genetic
scientist and the big reveal at the end
of the two-season event will be that the
children were the solution to saving the
world the entire time
hidden inside their genetic code
meanwhile when we rejoin rick in the
movies it'll be in the third crm
facility located in pennsylvania so what
do you think am i right
am i wrong the bummer is if i'm right
everyone's just going to write this
theory off as oh this was a sponsored
video so they told you when in actuality
that would have been dumb of them
no i just did a bunch of research and
feel really good about the conclusions
that we reached today they're based in
science they're based in
in universe lore and quite frankly all
the info that the creators of these
shows are spilling out to us
just shows that it pays to pay attention
to all parts of a fascinating and
carefully plotted out universe like this
one so now all that's left is for us to
tune into the premiere of world beyond
and see how immediately wrong
i am feel free to come back here and rub
it in my face
until those reveals happen or until my
predictions get spoiled beyond belief
remember
it's all just a theory a film
theory thanks to amc the walking dead
world beyond for sponsoring this video
and cut
you